AFTERNOON I'M I'D LIKE TO CALL
TO ORDER THIS HEARING OF THE
ASSEMBLY EDUCATION COMMITTEE
AND IT DOESN'T SEEM AS IF WE
HAVE A QUORUM SO WE'LL GO AHEAD
AND GET STARTED. AS A SUB
COMMITTEE. WE HAVE ONE BILL ON
THE AGENDA TODAY AB THIRTEEN OH
THREE. ASSEMBLY MEMBER
O'DONNELL WHENEVER YOU'RE
READY. THANK YOU MADAM CHERRY
THIRTEEN OH THREE. EXTENDS A
SUNSET DATE ON SCHOOL DISTRICT
AUTHORITY. TO ASSESS FEES FOR
THE USE OF RECREATIONAL SPACE.
EXISTING LAW. AUTHORIZES SCHOOL
DISTRICTS YOU CHARGE AMOUNT NOT
TO EXCEED DIRECT COSTS. FOR THE
USE OF SCHOOL FACILITIES SUCH
AS UTILITIES AND JANITORIAL
SERVICES. UNTIL JANUARY FIRST
TWENTY TWENTY DIRECT COSTS ALSO
INCLUDE. THE SHARE OF THE
COSTS. FOR THE MAINTENANCE OR
REPAIR FOR THE USE OF ANY NON
CLASSROOM AREAS SUCH AS
ATHLETIC FIELDS. EXCESSIVE WEAR
AND TEAR RESULT IN INCREASED
CAUGHT INCREASED COST TO
MAINTAIN AND REPAIR GROUNDS AND
INCREASES LIABLE AND INCREASES
LIABILITY. SHOULD INJURIES
OCCUR. THIS BILL WILL ALL
SCHOOL DISTRICTS TO SHARE
FACILITIES FOR COMMUNITY USE.
WHILE ENSURING SAFETY FOR ALL
USERS. WITH THAT FIVE A WITNESS
HERE TODAY ERIC ROCKY FROM THE
CALIFORNIA SCHOOL BOARDS
ASSOCIATION MANAGER. ERROR BY
THE CALIFORNIA SCHOOL BOARDS
ASSOCIATION A PROUD SUPPORTER
THIS LEGISLATION WE WERE THE
ORIGINAL OR WHEN I WAS WITH LOS
ANGELES UNIFIED WITH ORIGINAL.
FIRST TIME I FLIPPED UP ON THAT
THE ORIGINAL SPONSORS OF THIS
LEGISLATION FORTINO FOR ITS
SMART BILL IT ALLOWS FOR A
COMMENSURATE COSTS. THAT ARE
FAIR AND REASONABLE TO ENSURE
THE SAFETY OF OUR KIDS USING
THE FACILITIES. WE URGE YOUR
SUPPORT. THANK YOU. SMART
.
RIGHT IS THERE ANYONE HERE WHO
WOULD LIKE TO SPEAK IN SUPPORT
OF THE MEASURE. THE STATION
CALIFORNIA SCHOOL
ADMINISTRATORS AND STUFF. YEAH
ALL THIS SIDE OF A MOUNTAIN OF
THE DIFFICULT. FOR ANYONE IN
THE AUDIENCE IN OPPOSITION.
RIGHT SEEING NONE WE WILL
SIMPLY WAIT TO ESTABLISH CARMEN
WILL GO AHEAD AND VOTE. THREE
SECONDS BEFORE WE TALK. RECENT
O'NEILL'S
. WHICH
. YEAH YEAH
.
ONLY AVAILABLE. YEAH
. EDUCATION.
WHEN YOU MAKE A. HELLO WELCOME
TO THE MEMBERS WHO HAVE JOINED
US AT THE SECRETARIAL PLEASE
IT'S CALLED ROLLED ESTABLISH
FORM. O'DONNELL. TIME O'DONNELL
HERE KILEY. KILEY HERE KALRA
MCCARTY SMITH SMITH HERE VOEPEL.
VOEPEL HERE WEBER OVER HERE.
THANK YOU SO NOW THAT WE'VE
ESTABLISHED QUORUM AND WE HAVE
HEARD TESTIMONY IF THE
SECRETARY WILL PLEASE CLARIFY
THE MOTION. THE MOTION IS THAT
THE SENATE AMENDMENT SPEAKING
CURTAIN O'DONNELL. O'DONNELL
AYE KILEY. KILEY AYE KALRA
MCCARTY MCCARTY AYE SMITH. CALL
SORRY KALRA I'D RATHER MCCARTY
SMITH SMITH I VOEPEL. I WEBER
WEBER I. REGULATIONS THANK YOU
FOR YOUR SUPPORT. WELL WE THE
ROLE OPEN FOR ADAMS AND IN THIS
COMMITTEE MEETING ANSWERED.
ALSO EMISSIONS. IS ON THE EMAIL.
THE FOR A VERY SPECIAL. ALL
THOSE RECORDS ARE. IT'S NOT THE
SAME AS WHEN I. WE. THEY TAKE
UP ON ONE. YEAH. WE'RE DOING.
THE ONLY. ONE AB. NUMBER WHICH
IS A GREAT INVENTION NATIONAL
TIRE. NO ONE. ON THE NIGHT
. I
THINK THIS IS A. BECAUSE THAT.
YEAH A- THE. THAT WOULD
. I HAVE